Всіх вітаю дуже рада вас бачити Мене і
ми сьогодні упаковуємо 65ся продуктових
наборів частину запакували вчора частину
сьогодні і до нас сьогодні долучилось
дуже багато активістів від справи громад
е Які вони зробили свій внесок щоб бути
сьогодні тут на конвеєрі їх можна легко
ідентифікувати по футболках справа
громад благодійник тому що сьогодні дві
події перша подія - Це звісно останній
день конвеєра останній день упаковки ось
цих продуктових наборів в таких коробках
а друга подія - це один рік виповнився
справі громад нам вже один рік ми вже
дорослі і ми будемо з Вам Вам сьогодні
розповідати про нашу діяльність також і
в принципі хочу поспілкуватись з людьми
попитати їхні враження від конвеєру тому
що я вам вже показувала багато разів що
тут відбувається Хто дивився наші
попередні стріми ви і так все знаєте але
тут якби справа в людях які сьогодні
долучились до нас і з ними варто
поспілкуватись тому
Ходімо у
на Добрий день Добрий день прямий ефір
ви приїхали звідки Херсон з Херсона
приїхали до нас активісти Розкажіть як
вам сьогодні
тут для мене це свято чесно тому що
справа громад - це моє улюблене го
останній рік і я сподіваюсь що воно буде
моє улюблений ще багато-багато років Е
дуже такий двіж крутий е офігенний всі
завзяті
всі відповідальні всі з Україною в серці
тому сьогодні це для мене свято це дуже
об'єднує Дякую бачите тут у нас
активісти з багатьох міст України Я вам
навіть на пам'ять не назву всі але дуже
багато із заходу це і Львів і
івано-франківськ і Коломия і та також є
із Дніпра із Харкова із Херсона з
Тернополя дуже багато активістів
Антоніна Привіт Як тобі сьогоднішня наше
Нарешті остання упаковка я вам обещала
что это будет под фанфары Вот они
фанфары это круто это на самом деле я
вибачаюся тільки українською Уляна Дідич
Привіт тобі тільки для тебе ну і для
всіх сьогодні дуже важливий для нас день
тому що цей проект це таке така як
кажуть Вишенка на тортик завершення
нашого першеоріччя Всі ви знаєте что ну
офіційно завтра але ми будемо святкувати
Сьогодні у нас рік і от цей рік так
завершиється як для мене це те дуже
символічно тому що ми не тільки про
політику а щей про
благодійність Тобто ми можемо багато ще
багатше А якщо ви можете багато то
робіть це тому що ці добрі справи це
дуже важливо для нашої країни Зараз і
будуть буде мабуть важливо завжди Тому я
дуже-дуже вдячна тим людям які сьогодні
з нами Я дуже вдячна європейської
солідарності нашому лідеру ажеж він
тут всім вам хто дивиться Хто
допомагає Приєднуйтесь до нас тому що
ззнами дійсно круто дяку знащо написали
сьогодні в чатику написали сьогодні в
чатику щоеленсь скаржеся на кадровий
голод бо Всі кадри в справі громад
Уявляєш так так і є але ще не всі ви ще
встигнете стати нашими кадрами справо
громад ми вас Запрошуємо У нас є
сторінки у соціальних мережах це взагалі
ми є у всіх соцмережах тому просто можна
зайти в Google написати справа громад і
якби ви знайдете одразу ж потрапите туди
куди
треба можна до нас
долучитись
Добрий день Я бачу що ви справа громад
Полтави із Полтави до нас приїхали так з
Полтави Як вам враження від конвеєру від
сьогоднішнього враження чудові дуже
позитивні емоції дуже багато людей з
усієї України Ну просто круто Нереально
круто хоч кожного дня до вас приїжджаю
Це точно Дякую Як вам взагалі От вже рік
в справі громад Це круто Це об'єднує це
однозначно
круто у нас нещодавно створився осередок
буквально два місяці але до нас
долучилися вже дуже багато людей
справжніх українців дуже активних людей
які хочуть щось змінювати щось робити і
які хочуть щоб Україна була справжньою
Україною ті хто дивиться нас із Полтави
як до вас долучитись написати вам в
Facebook Ми є в фейсбуку Ми є в
Інстаграмі шукайте нас справа громад
солідарна Полтава або справа громад
Полтава за НАТО та ЄС у нас два осередки
тому можете обирати будь-який
і приєднуєся Приєднуйтесь Ми вас чекаємо
ми завжди знайдемо чим вас
зайняти У нас дуже багато проектів
місцевого плану і ми чекаємо активних
людей Класно дякую Я маю надію що після
цього ефіру до нас долучаться люди до
справи громад Полтава Дякую що ви тут
Дякую Тут дівчата запаковують борошно
можу одразу показати термін
придатності все у нас свіже Я показувала
вже у стрімі на справі громад Ось
запаковано
26.04.20 бачите показувала абсолютно всі
продукти все свіже покажу ще раз Мені не
важко це важливо Я розумію
прекрасно тут у нас ще є люди а можна
вас на пару
слів так Так у нас прямий
ефір ви звідки до нас приїхали з Дніпра
з Дніпра ви мене в масці не впізнаєте ви
вже ВД Він молодий з
бородою я би зняв маску ну не
можна Як вам враження від того що
сьогодні тут відбувається клас Мені дуже
подобається інтенсивність швидкість і
корисність того що ми робимо І взагалі
оце от єднання навіть футболочки дають
нам якусь єдність таку
приємну Круто Я вважаю що це хороша
справа абсолютно
ні Людей багато хто потребує дійсно
допомоги і Це неймовірно корисно а хто
ви розвозили в Полтаві що люди кажуть не
в Полтаві в Дніпрі Ой перепрошую в
Дніпрі щойно спілкувалась полта возили
так ну люди вдячні Літні люди
просто сльзами на очах тобто дякують і
це підкреслює цю от необхідність знаєте
навіть не відчувається що настільки люди
потребують допомоги ну знову ж таки
списки з в2020 там люди котрі дійсно
потребують ну онули скрутній ситуації
скажемо так у зв'язку з коронавірусом
дуже багато хто Втратив роботу зараз не
може працювати І досі не можуть
працювати оскільки до кінця карантинні
заходи ще не зняті тобто ця допомога
думаю буде дуже актуальна для багатьох
Дякую що долучаєтесь допомагаєте
Це той самий Дмитро кошка який молодий з
бородою Так я його впізнала може глядачі
напишуть
впізнають ідентифікувати у нас Навіть є
маленькі благодійники які сьогодні
долучилися бачите дівчинка передає
борошно на конвеєр і так знаєте вона так
класно допомагає дуже багато роботи
хорошої
[музика]
робить а можна вас на
секундочку на секундочку на пару слів в
нас прямий ефір ви теж з Полтави
приїхали що скажете про сьогоднішній
день неймовірно день і цей день надихає
дуже на те щоб іти далі і працювати
разом з європейською
солідарністю робити гарні справи І я
дуже щаслива що ми долучилися що ми
змогли приїхати і що нас запросили на це
дійство тому що це неймовірні почуття
неймовірні емоції і велика наснага для
нас на майбутнє працювати даліже краще
краще і краще дякую не буду вас
відволікати Дякую щирі слова насправді
так класно так надихає
дуже Я пропоную якось нам потрапити в
той бік до людей поспілкуватися але не
знаю як давайте Ось так
обійде ось ось так такий
маршрут тут у нас коробки подають на
конвеєр
бачите складають сюди
борошно Як вам враження від конвеєру
Добрий день прямий ефір добрий день ну
приємно що робимо добру справу якби
втомлюєшся але ця втома
приємна це ви складаєте цукор Ага цукор
а Дайте мені будь ласка пачечку цукру
одну Дякую дивіться ось такий цукор ми
складаємо сьогодні і хочу вам показати
термін придатності Я для цього попросила
ось цукор збирають 2019 року Урожай
зібрано а 20-го року запаковано
21.05 і зберігається це він десь рік о
отири роки отири роки його можна
споживати Так що все
свіже вже насправді завершуємо упаковку
бачите мало коробок дуже
[музика]
залишилось можна одне слово добрий день
прямий ефір що скажете про сьогоднішній
день е ну Це крута дуже атмосфера ми
сиділи у Львові спостерігали за
попередніми і ви зі Львова Так я зі
львоваїли актисти так що вітання
відійської справи
она зупиняється
веє От і
чесно відверто заздрали і це потрапити
сюди Ну це неймовірні Відчуття це навіть
цінніше ніж те що передавалось на відео
тобто відео цього не передає та
я так намагаюсь постійно передати
глядачам але вони все одно того як
частково в Ну бо я ж попередні дивилася
власне і це це абсолютно зовсім інше Це
відчуття плеча відчуття спільного що ми
всі разом ну це направду дуже сильно Які
результати роботи справа громад за рік
краще ніж у
президента Ну слухай ну не можна
порівнювати
ні насправді В нас у Львові дуже дуже
непогано Я знаю що у вас активний
осередок ви багато чого корисного робите
так намагаємося ми і допомагаємо
європейській солідарності з організацією
акції своїї робимо ну передкарантин
трошки зупинив таку активну діяльність
Так є таке чому підійду щоб не зупиняти
але зараз намагаємося через онлайн
організовувати якісь активності ну і
зараз
вже на завтра в нас так само справа
громад активно бере участь в організації
стопреванш якось так Так дякую
дякую в нас прямий ефір Да
я до речі долучилась і Пані Марина
Порошенко і її
донька А там її двоє
дітей бачу теж Всі долучаються до цієї
роботи Все класно воно
[музика]
об'єднує
можна поки що я я тут я тут я тут Добрий
день Пару слів про враження від конвеєру
сьогоднішнього прямий ефір как обычно
Все в порядке
приехали з Миколаєва бачите люди
приїхали Ну ми розвозили в області їх по
області розвозили от На
жаль влада яка
зараз народ
вибрав не стримую свого слова що вони за
рік тають всі дороги і ми б'ємо свої
машини але людям це потрібно і ми це
робимо приїжджаємо сюди їдемо По
регіонах тобто навіть стикаєтесь з
такими труднощами з труднощами з доріг
стикаєтесь навіть Я такого не чула ще
нічого собі Та ні ви що якщо віддалені
села то 5-7 км/годи ми йдемо такі ями що
і машина тоне але все одно доставляєте
всім А що люди кажуть яким ви привозите
Дякую і плачу не
вірять На жаль
більшість Влада не
прорахувала
певний алгоритм дій під час пандемії що
людям буде потрібно скорочуються робочі
місця люди сиділи без без зарплат без
ніякої допомоги і просто люди плачуть
тому що на 1 там 800 900 неможливо
прожити навіть Пен тому що в нього є
величезна кількість видатків на
фармакологічні якісь засоби бо людина
хворіє вже Ну 50-60 я не знаю людей які
не хворіють От і більшість їхнього
бюджету уходить на аптеку А залишається
трішечки на поїсти і вони не можуть
зараз купити тому що супермаркети вони
ціни підняли ті які працюють а в
регіонах нічого не працює всі же
Позакривали і це був тре їхати там
найближче там райцентр або когось
просити щоб з міста привезли розумієте А
це все трафік це надбавка на ціну Так
звісно це дуже важко особливо ризикувати
здоров'ям якщо це дуже Літні люди це
реально Дякую за те що допомагаєте це
дуже така Істо
Укра буде завдяки таким людям
буде що ви скажете про конвеєр сьогодні
добрий день пару слів прямий ефір я
скажу вперше Мені пощастило попасти і
звідки я зараз живу в Києві але я вперше
На цьому заході дуже мріла і я в захвиті
бути серед людей які хтять ро створити
добро це просто я в захвисті я в захвиті
що справа громад взагалі ініціювала цю
акцію і я дуже рада що в нах є такі
серед них Дякую це
круто
Ось так бачите коробочки рухаються Ой я
вам забула продукти
показати показати покажемо продукти
свіжі Ходімо
[музика]
покажемо це у нас
рис
А ми
завершили
слава Слава нації
Смерть
Україна Слава Україні і нашій
Українській армії я вам все ж таки
покажу наші продукти так ось вжити до 15
а нініні ось дата фасування 9.05 20
бачите це рис складали таі в
коробочки потім що
ще соняшникова олія У нас така
була
а десь тут дата ось
2703.20го
олія
[музика]
є
сильні
разом у нас рік справи громад будемо
святкувати можемо ще показати куди ідуть
коробки ну тобто ми їхось з конвеєра тут
забираємо і далі вони всі всі
всі ось їх тут люди попідписували це
класно дуже
[музика]
дивіться Україна понад усе ми з вами Ви
не самі не хворійте Бережіть себе так
класно
щиро будьте здорові Слава Україні
Бажаємо здоров'я слава героям сонечко
[музика]
намалювали і далі їх тут завантажують в
авто з цього
боку
пан ахтем чийгост сьогодні долучився Як
вам сьогоднішній конвеєр останній Вже
так
от Дай Боже щоб зовсім все по
коронавірусу на цему і завершились але я
так вважаю що
ще трохи Треба буде суспільству не
росслаблятись і бути такими згуртованими
тому
що тому що треба щоб Україна завжди була
українці щоб вони були згуртовані є і
інші виклики і ми от як всі гуртом
противостоїмо зараз цьому ви виклику і
іншим також будемо противостояти гуртом
стовідсотково
Дякую можемо ще піти поспілкуватись з
активістами їх сьогодні багато чи всі
міста Я встигла опитати зараз дізнаємось
Так кого впізнаю з інших міст з тим ми
поспілкуємось Добрий день прямий ефір що
скажете про
конвеєр не зрозумів питання прямий ефір
що скажете про конвеєр який ваші
враження е Шкода що вже закінчився Він
дуже шкода дуже сумно якось надо якийсь
новий проект по-любому придумувать 100%
бо це об'єднує правда Так так так так
так дуже сподобалось дуже
безмежно емоцій цього всього і дуже
шкода що закінчився Класно дякую вам що
долучились кого я ще не
запитувала пару слів буквально прямий
ефір ваші просто враження бо зараз такий
момент якраз коли емоції є і я у вас їх
хочу почути
Ну в общем мы довольны нашим результатом
и вообще мы делали это всё для людей с
добрым сердцем с чистыми помыслами на
здоровье на благополучие конечно главный
спонсор всего этого действия мы знаем
что
был Петро Порошенко
вот ему за это большая благодарность
потомуз всего такого бы не
получилось но я считаю что всем кто это
делал кто физически морально
психологически материально помогал вот
всем этим людям воздаст Вот так как они
это делали от чистого сердца и Всё
вернётся старице И всем этим людям так
Что сделали благое дело дай Бог эти
наборы помогли кому-то
кому-то может быть даже и в очень
скрутно громад п разом общем мы Всем
спасибо бжить
фотографуватись Всі благодійники до
нас
дкуюіх буде видноходьте біг по
Присідайте внизу ша а тидаває ди на
[музика]
пале так всі на мене будь ласка
улагу
[музика]
громай
щоб ви розуміли більшість із цих
активістів Сьогодні приїхали з різних
куточків України коли дізнались що буде
Останній конвеєр і можна бути тут
[музика]
[оплески]
присутнілава
[музика]
що
побудувалися
[музика]
так так
так
[музика]
покажіть фоткущо вийшло кого вийшло
покажть всіх
вийшли покажіть в кого
[музика]
вийшло
А де черга
замставати
дякую
[музика]
зараз
дкую
[музика]
Так я тут ра робила
варіа вийшли
фотки покажіть ще раз покажіть Це прямий
ефір
покажіть
[музика]
а
кноми трошки всі в різні сторони
дивимося на
[музика]
клас це класно це емоційно Дякую що
дивились цей прямий
ефір робіть добрі справи долучайтесь До
нас нас можна знайти просто в Google
введіть справа громад і ви знайдете і
можете долучитись до нас і стати також
благодійниками або активістами у себе в
місті в нас є багато осередків де можна
долучитися А ми будемо продовжувати
робити добрі справи поділіться будь
ласка цим відео поставте вподобайку а
також підпишіться на YouTube канал
європейської солідарності щоб не
пропускати прямі ефіри щоб бути з нами
постійно на зв'язку з вами була Марія
мадзігон знімав мене Андрій Луганський
дякує му велике за це і
[музика]
побачимось